- Hi!
- I mean, that is a good thing of like,
you are wearing that dress,
that dress is, that's nice.
(applause)
It's so cute.
- Thank you!
- [Kelly] I love it. It's
very fall. I'm very in to it.
Um, so we had your co-star
J.B. Smoove here recently,
and I heard, did you give him puppies?
- Yes!
- [Kelly] Do you often
give people puppies?
- No, I was dying to get
rid of these puppies.
But my dogs had puppies, she had eight.
My dog Liddy. And they were, you know,
- [Cheryl] they're cute for a second.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.
- [Cheryl] Yeah, those are the,
that's the mom and the dad.
And so they had puppies
and I took some of them
to The Curb set,
- [Kelly] You're like, here.
- [Cheryl] Can anybody take
these? And Larry's like, no.
And, and J.B. said, oh,
I like them. I like them.
Let me talk to my wife Shah,
let's see if she likes them.
And they came over and they
played with all the puppies
and they were like, we'll take those two.
- They took two.
- [Cheryl] Yes. They took two.
- Oh, I love that.
- Hustle and Flow.
(applause)
- [Kelly] No, they didn't.
- Yes, they named them Hustle
and Flow. (Kelly laughing)
- [Cheryl] They're the
cutest! Is that the cutest?
- That's the greatest name,
that's awesome. Hustle and Flow.
Okay, so wait. Have you ever been there
for any other births in life?
- Well, okay. Besides my dog Liddy.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Um, I was there when
my sister had a C-section
- Oh.
- [Cheryl] I was like holding her hand.
- Did you see that?
- Well, they had a little curtain.
- Oh yeah. I was there with mine.
- You had the curtain.
- You were on this side.
- I was on the good side.
- Yeah
- and, um, but my sister and I
This is sort of a crazy
story because we looked up
and my family was looking
through one of those windows.
You know how you can observe a, surgery.
- They were all looking?
- [Cheryl] They were looking.
And we looked up and we started laughing.
And my sister, my sister was like,
"Oh my God. What's happening?"
And we started laughing.
And the doctor said,
"I've never had to say this before,
but you need to stop laughing.
Cause it's going to be
bad for the babies."
- Oh my gosh. But I need to come back to,
everyone's looking in a window down on.
- I know.
- I just need to.
- No, rewind that. Yeah.
- Yeah.
- Because I don't have to happened.
- [Kelly] Me neither. I mean,
do you want to see that?
- No!
- Oh no!
- [Cheryl] Who would want to see that?
And how did my family get to
that window? I don't know.
- [Kelly] Did your sister say it was like,
I feel like me and my
sister talking about it,
it's like there, cause you can't feel,
but it's like, they're
gardening inside of you.
- [Cheryl] They're like pulling and stuff.
- Yeah. They literally,
it's like the craziest
thing in the world.
- Like pressure.
- Yeah.
- But you can't feel.
- Yeah
- I was out of it. God
bless, God bless medicine.
I was like, not talking clear, like.
So you, speaking of your
family though, you come,
you and your husband
come from big families.
So do you all get excited
about family holidays or do you
start getting stressed out.
- Uh both? No, I'm more
excited, more excited.
- [Kelly] That's a true answer.
- But you know what? Do
you come from a big family?
- No.
- [Cheryl] Oh, so you can buy
real gifts for each other.
- I bought. Do you want
to know something great?
I'm all bought up. I've done
all my Christmas shopping.
Like really ahead of the game.
- Really?
- Yes. But I don't come
from a huge family.
It's like literally my sister
and her family, my mom.
- [Cheryl] Oh that's
nice. That's reasonable.
- But I do have friends
families, people, I do. Yeah.
- Um, we have a big family.
So you can't really buy
Christmas presents for
everybody. You would go broke.
- [Kelly] There's that many of them.
So, you know, we do the thing.
- And it's just hard to be thoughtful.
- No. We.
- How can you be that
thoughtful for everyone.
- You aren't. That's how it happens.
And so we do this like
white elephant, Christmas.
- [Kelly] I love that.
- You buy one, good gift,
and I use the term loosely,
with my group. And you, you know,
you put them all in the middle of the room
and then everybody picks a number.
And if you go first, you pick one,
you open it. And then if I go second,
I can steal yours or I can pick a new one.
And it goes around the room and it gets,
- That takes the pressure off.
- Yeah, but it gets a little violent.
- Oh, cause then you can steal the gifts.
- You can steal.
- I do like a white elephant gift party.
- And, you know,
- [Kelly] I'm competitive though.
- Oh, I'm so competitive.
- So Does anyone ever
get in a fight over it?
Like of who gets,
- [Cheryl] Oh yeah, fight, yes.
- You know, there's the one
good one that everybody is like,
I want that one.
- Well because, if you have
like a friend come over,
they, they actually buy a good gift.
(laughter)
- [Cheryl] And so that's the
one that you want. Meanwhile,
there's like a can of
boiled peanuts, you know,
that goes flying through
the air. It's like,
I don't want these.
And it's just like you're
ducking and bobbing and weaving
- I love your family. Sounds fun.
- It's a fun, uh, it's a fun group.
- It creates memories.
- [Kelly] It's hysterical.
The show is so funny,
but I did find this out.
Larry, doesn't tell you like,
what's happening until you
start doing the scene, right?
- [Cheryl] Right.
- That's terrifying.
(Cheryl laughing)
- [Cheryl] he writes a story outline
and then we improvise all of the dialogue.
So sometimes he doesn't
even tell me what it's about
until we start rolling.
And then I find out
while he's talking.
- [Kelly] Have you ever found
something out during this,
that like, caught you off guard?
- Yes. And there have been a few times.
I mean, there was one season,
it's so sad where I leave him.
- And you didn't know
that was about to happen?
- [Cheryl] No. I did. I
did. But, but you know,
there's no rehearsal because
there there's no script.
And so when we started doing it,
I start crying because
I'm like, oh my God.
And Larry's like, "Don't, don't cry."
(clapping)
- [Cheryl] That's not funny.
- So nurturing.
- [Cheryl] He was like, "You can't cry."
I was like, but it's sad.
I just, I'm leaving you.
And he's like, "Cheryl, pull
it together. It's a comedy."
- [Kelly] Be a robot.
(Cheryl laughing)
- [Cheryl] So yeah, once in
a while, there's something
where you just. Oh, you know, but people
are always really funny and
they say crazy funny things.
- [Kelly] How do you not laugh?
- [Cheryl] I usually bite
the inside of my cheek.
- [Kelly] Okay, really,
cause I'm like how does?
- I have to.
- I had to do a scene one
time. I hate acting in general,
and the only reason why I said yes,
was cause it was with Robin Williams.
And he improvised it all
and he makes you laugh.
And I'm like, that's
not fair I'm a singer.
Like it's, I'm not like
a, really an actor.
I didn't take like a class to be like,
this is how you don't laugh. Like yeah.
So you bite your cheek.
- That's what I do.
- I know, it was really
hard. I almost snotted
all over myself cause I was holding it in
and then it just, I was like,
it was so funny. Anyway,
so you visited your old
improv acting class recently.
So do you, do you have any
memorable auditions back then?
- Well, you know, before I had an agent,
I was auditioning for um,
um, student films, you know,
because those filmmakers are
going to go on and be great
filmmakers. So, and it was
good experience as an actor.
So I, I was auditioning for a lot.
- [Kelly] I love this.
- [Cheryl] This is like.
I think this is like,
- [Kelly] This is my favorite.
- When I first got there.
- [Kelly] Hey, you know what?
Fanny packs are now back in.
- They are. Circle, I circled around.
But I went to this audition
and these two guys were like,
so here, it's a short film,
you and your husband are
watching animal planet.
You're eating TV dinners,
the animals start mating.
And then you get the idea.
- [Kelly] You're inspired.
Is this your way of saying
you were in a porn?
(laughter)
- [Cheryl] An animal porn, thank you.
- [Kelly] Is this your way, is this code?
(applause)
- So I was like, I'm not
sure what the audition is.
And they said, well, you just
start making animal noises.
Like, what would an elephant
sound like if they were mating?
(Kelly laughing)
- [Cheryl] And I was like, I'm
just going to stomp it down.
This is what I'm going to have to,
I'm going to have to walk out on this.
Cause you know, these students are just.
- I was so hoping you did
it and you had the footage
and we could play it.
(laughter)
- Oh gosh. Could you imagine?
Yeah, no, then when we go through a lot of
different animal sounds.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.
- Like monkeys and elephants.
I was like, this is, no.
- You should do this, you
should go that improv thing
and sit in the audience,
and then shout it out
so they would have to do it.
- Monkey's mating! Monkey's mating!
- Monkey's mating! Go!
- They'd be like, is that Cheryl?
(clapping)
(Kelly laughing)
- So were you, were you ever asked
to do impressions of
humans? At an audition?
Are you good at that?
- Uh, apparently, no.
I had to auditioned for,
I think it was one of the
what's one of the, I don't
even remember the name
of the movie now. Like a
Scream. It was one of the funny.
- Like a scary movie?
- [Cheryl] Oh! Scary Movie.
- Oh, it's called, Scary
Movie. Yeah, the Scary Movies.
- It was like Scary Movie 3 or something.
And the whole audition was in the, oh, um,
that was auditioning in, in the film.
The mom from the Exorcist,
takes the priest's hat
and is about to hang it up
when she catches herself
in the mirror and she puts
it on and realizes, oh,
I should do a Michael
Jackson impersonation.
And so my whole audition was me,
(screaming)
(laughter)
and I am like moon walking
and dancing around and um
- What?
- Yeah, it was one of those,
like out of body experience.
I saw myself and it was like, no, no.
Don't, don't, don't moonwalk.
- [Kelly] Don't do it.
Don't moonwalk. And I did.
- [Kelly] You did it.
- I sure did.
- [Kelly] You leaned in?
I leaned in and um, didn't get it.
- [Kelly] And they leaned out.
- They leaned out.
- [Kelly] They leaned out.
- I heard that they ended up not using
the scene in the film or something.
Like somebody may have said something
to make me feel better. I don't know.
- [Kelly] I feel that they
just didn't need that part.
- [Cheryl] They did not need that part.
- That's random. You've
had, you've been asked
to do random things.
- [Cheryl] The life of an actors. Crazy.
One time I had to audition
for an eight month pregnant
lifeguard, who got bitten by a shark.
- [Kelly] What?
- [Cheryl] But no words.
- [Kelly] All the hurdles.
- [Cheryl] No words. Just, ahh.
- [Kelly] No words? Was it a silent film.
- It was a reenactment.
(laughter)
- I was like, wait, I was like.
- So, they were talking while
you would see me reenact it.
- [Kelly] Oh.
(gasping)
(laughing)
- [Kelly] Oh my god, I love your life.
- Also, didn't get that one.
(clapping)
(laughing)
- You got the good ones.
- [Cheryl] I got the good ones.